welcome everyone uh i'm priya natarajan
i'm the current director of the frankie
program in science in the humanities at
yale
and i am delighted to have you all
attend today's distinguished speaker
series talk with kirk wallace johnson
i'm delighted to see you all though we
are still virtual we were hoping to meet
you in person first
i would like to take a moment
of silence to honor those who are
vulnerable in the face of the ongoing
senseless war
our collective humanity is under threat
and we stand in solidarity with all of
those who are suffering right now so
let's just take a few moments of silence
before we start
our celebratory events today
okay so let's join in to celebrate
of the wonderful imagination of
a human mind kirks
and his book the feather thief beauty
obsession and the natural his uh history
heist of the century but before we set
off
i would like to thank uh mr and mrs
richard and barbara frankie for their
generous support
of multiple interdisciplinary activities
at yale a flagship of which is the
frankie program in science and the
humanities thank you so much they are in
attendance today with jane frankie
and i know that we have a draw of a very
wide audience today from near and far
and we are pleased to welcome all the
enthusiastic naturalists and bird
watchers in addition to a loyal
following who have helped us build and
sustain our community through the very
isolating and difficult past two years
of the pandemic
so glad to be emerging from that
darkness into health happiness and light
for all of us i just want to remind you
that we are recording this event and
that all participants will therefore
have their videos muted for the duration
of the talk
please feel free to type in your
questions and you may submit them at any
time in the q a feature in our webinar
i would
well i want to start today by
introducing
someone who doesn't need an introduction
rick prum the william robertson
co-professor of ornithology and the
curator of ornithology and head curator
of vertebrate zoology at yale's peabody
museum of natural history
rick is the former director of the
frankie program and is a renowned
scientist and acclaimed author many of
you
might have read his best selling the
evolution of beauty and i gather he has
a brand new book that is expected to be
out very soon
his list of seminal contributions to our
understanding of the theory of evolution
and his recognitions and honors awards
are too numerous to recount so in the
interest of time
i will hand over the proceedings to him
in just a little bit this afternoon but
before i do that i would like to mention
a couple of our ongoing projects and a
few upcoming events i wanted to remind
you about our learning by doing project
which
showcases
stem videos so please contribute take a
look at our webpage
and we have a couple of interesting
upcoming events we have the ongoing
inference project talk and discussion
the next talk will be given by kyle
cranmer on wednesday march 9th at 4 pm
on zoom and the discussion will be a
week later on march 16th at the same
time with zenna tavares
the distinguished speaker series talk
the next one will be by carl zimmer and
he will be talking to us on his book
life's edge the search for what it means
to be alive on wednesday march 30th at 4
pm
both these events will actually be uh
virtual we are really hoping to meet in
convenient person in april and we are
hoping to debut that with
mapping as knowing lecture series talk
by the musicologist victor coelho
on april 13th and we are hoping it will
be in person in the new humanities
quadrangle
and also watch the space the uh
acclaimed uh jazz musician vijay iyer we
are hoping to
have a live event in april um hopefully
anyway thank you rick for offering to
introduce our wonderful speaker kirk
uh take it away
thank you thanks very much priya and uh
uh i think for that uh overly kind
introduction
it is a pleasure to introduce kirk
wallace johnson a best-selling author
and journalist and if i can add an
adventurer and uh storyteller par
excellence uh kirk was
educated at the university of chicago
and later did a fulbright scholar uh
research in egypt uh studying uh
political islamism
um he worked at uh afterwards in iraq
with the u.s agency for international
development in baghdad
and his experience in iraq and following
uh that experience
was the uh core of his uh first book uh
uh in 2014 to be a friend is fatal the
flight to save
iraqi americans left behind
or the iraqis america left behind
this book was described by george packer
as a
riveting darkly funny heroic
and shaming
and was a a
a deeply affecting book
his
2019 book the feather thief beauty
obsession and the natural history heist
of the century the subject of today's
lecture
was also best-selling and usually
an unusual book in the niche of
ornithological true crime
and that's what we'll be hearing about
today
kirk has a book coming out in late
summer the fisherman and dr and the
dragon fear greed and a fight for
justice on the golf course which is
about uh immigrant vietnamese fishing
communities in texas and alabama so
uh
exciting events to come
kirk's writing has appeared in the new
yorker the new york times the washington
post
uh the wall street journal foreign
policy among among many others uh his
work has appeared several times as well
on the npr show this american life
including two rare hour-long programs on
these things um
uh kirk has uh uh is currently a usc
annenberg center
uh uh fellow uh on the commute uh center
is a fellow at the usc annenberg center
on communication leadership and policy
now uh in about 2012 or 13 at the
whitney humanities
center i was sitting down to lunch when
someone asked me uh do you know or have
you heard of edwin wrist
i almost fell out of my chair
because uh i thought that i was maybe
alone in the world of being obsessed
with edwin wrist
the my questioner told me that uh
she had a friend who was also obsessed
with edwin wrist and was thinking of
writing a book
uh i soon got in touch with kirk uh
about that and uh began a a marvelous
correspondence soon we realized we had
to meet and kirk visited in new haven uh
for a marvelous couple days where we
talked about feathers endlessly and i
talked about
feathered anatomy and development and
uh and and uh and and on and on uh
really kirk had sort of a mini graduate
seminar in better biology uh uh over
those days
um
of course um
uh
uh
kirk went on to uh uh do further
research which is the subject of the
book so i won't i won't go any further
except to pick um
one little uh bone of contention that
i'm going to raise and that is uh
um
when the book came out uh
i was portrayed as a one
potty-mouthed ornithology
in fact that feat became the teaser at
the top of the hour in the you know the
beginning of act two uh in in this
american life so much so that uh when my
uh mother's friends i said i heard your
son on npr and she asked me well why
didn't you tell me you were going to be
on npr i was a i was uh
afraid to tell her but in fact
you know i must say in the every in the
years with heavy rotation of this
program in the year since uh every once
in a while i'll get an email from an old
high school friend or from an
acquaintance from long past saying hey i
heard you on fdr
uh usually always referring to the same
moments now well the moment is a you
know a an enthusiastic and um
highly energetic expletive uh which
which featured uh in both the book and
in this
and i just want to say now uh you know i
had hoped for more balanced portrayal uh
but i know in the interest of of of of
the story uh that uh uh uh which was
indeed riveting uh that that's the
source of it so i just wanted to report
on that and i i just want also to tell
you that uh kirk my mom is in the
audience today okay all right so i'm not
knocking your mouth now but
there it is take it away kirk and thanks
very much for uh for uh taking the time
to uh uh join us at the frank's program
uh
thank you for that kind kind intro rick
uh and
you have my apologies for that i would
just say
watch your mouth
when you talk to a journalist with a
recorder
um i want to thank yale and the and the
frankies for for having me uh this is a
this is a
you know i think part of the
the appeal that
people have uh
expressed about this book is that it
there's a bit of escapism to it and
we're in some particularly heavy times
and so um
even having written it i still
enjoy the opportunity to kind of dive
back into this story
um i'm going to
um since we're
we have the advantage to
look at some some pictures and videos
and audio i'm going to share my screen
here um and i'm going to open with a
i'm going to open with
a kind of startling piece of audio
[Music]
that happened during
one of the interviews don't worry rick
it's not it's not yours um but this is
uh
probably two years into my investigation
um
[Music]
speaking to a south african
uh victorian salmon fly tire who i
suspected
as having some of the stolen birds that
you'll hear about
um the fact that it happened i don't
think is shocking at all
um and it's not because of the feverish
demand or anything it's where there's
where something is scarce with something
is really difficult to get hold of
and you know there's enough people that
want to forget about the you know
feverish demand around it
people people are creative they're going
to find ways to source what they need
um and it really is as simple as that is
it
in terms of
severity of the crime and please i don't
know if you you know well you can quote
me on anything i don't really care but
in terms of severity of crimes this in
my opinion just doesn't rate that highly
these are
skins that are sitting in in cupboard
somewhere
do i condone it no not at all anything
that is wrong is wrong wrong is wrong
and rice is right it's as simple as that
for me the biggest shock was that it was
eggman
okay now i'm going to do a quick reading
from the prologue i don't
really like
reading very very often
partly because i have um
i have a five-year-old and a
four-year-old and i have this habit of
kind of breaking into a sing-song dr
seuss voice so uh forgive me if that
happens but i'm gonna read you
a brief passage from the prologue just
to kind of set the scene for those of
you who haven't read the book
this uh pertains to the events of of
june 23rd 2009.
by the time edwin risk stepped off the
train onto the platform at tring 40
miles north of london it was already
quite late the residents of the sleepy
town had finished their supper as the
little ones were in bed as he began a
long walk into town the train glided off
in the darkness
a few hours earlier edmund had performed
in the royal academy of music's london
soundscapes a celebration of haydn
handel and mendelson
before the concert he'd packed a pair of
latex gloves a miniature led flashlight
a wire cutter and a diamond blade glass
cutter and a large rolling suitcase and
stowed it in his concert hall locker
he bore a passing resemblance to a lanky
pete townsend intense eyes prominent
nose and a mop of hair although instead
of shredding a fender edwin played the
flute
there was already a new moon that
evening making the gloomy stretch of
road even darker
for nearly an hour he dragged his
suitcase through the mud and gravel
skirting the road under gnarly old trees
strangled with ivy a car blasted by its
headlights blinding adrenaline coursing
he knew he was getting close
the entrance to the market town of tring
is guarded by a 16th century pub called
the robin hood
a few roads beyond nestled between the
old tring brewery and an hsbc branch
lies the entrance to public footpath 37
known to locals as bank alley the
footpath isn't more than eight feet wide
and is framed by seven foot high brick
walls
edwin slipped into the alley into total
darkness he groped his way along until
he was standing directly behind the
building he'd spent months casing
all that separated him from it was the
wall
capped with three rusted strands of
barbed wire it might afford his plans
were it not for the wire cutter and
after clearing an opening he lifted the
suitcase to the ledge hoisted himself up
and glanced anxiously about no sign of
the guard
he reached toward the window with the
glass cutter and began to grind it along
the pain
cutting glass was harder than he had
anticipated though and as he struggled
the carbon opening the glass cutter
slipped from his hand his mind raised
was this a sign he was thinking about
bailing on the whole crazy scheme when
that voice the one that had urged him
onward these past months shouted wait a
minute you can't give up now
you've come all this way
he crawled back down and picked up a
rock studying himself atop the wall he
peered around in search of guards before
bashing the window out wedging his
suitcase to the shard strewn opening and
climbing into the british natural
history museum
unaware that he had just tripped an
alarm in the security guard's office
edwin pulled out the led light which
cast a faint glow in front of him as he
made his way down the hallways toward
the vault just as he rehearsed in his
mind
he wheeled his suitcase quietly through
corridor after corridor drawing ever
closer to the most beautiful things he'd
ever seen
if he pulled this off they would bring
him fame wealth and prestige they would
solve his problems he deserved them
he entered the vault it's hundreds of
large white steel cabinets standing in
rows like centuries and got to work he
pulled out the first drawer catching a
waft of mothballs quivering beneath his
fingertips were a dozen red rough fruit
crows gathered by naturalists and
biologists over hundreds of years from
the forests and jungles of south america
their coppery orange feathers glimmered
despite the faint light each bird maybe
a foot and a half from beak to tail lay
on its back and funerary repose
eye sockets filled with cotton feet
folded close against the body he
unzipped the suitcase and began filling
it with the birds emptying one drawer
after another
now
i'm going to interrupt myself
i'm under no obligation to
to say this or relay this but i'm
feeling generous towards the british
museum today so i i will say that this
of the for everything in the book this
is the one
thing that they dispute
but down in the security office the
guard was fixated on a small television
screen engrossed in a soccer match he
hadn't yet noticed the alarm indicator
blinking on a nearby panel
this led to a very surreal exchange with
with the british museum where they they
said there wasn't a soccer match
happening that that night i had to prove
that there was
uh and then they said that the guard
doesn't like soccer which to which i
replied you know
he does he's british i'm sure he does
but
anyways moving on edwin opened the next
cabinet to reveal dozens of resplendent
quetzal skins gathered in the 1880s from
the cherokee cloud forest of western
panama a species now threatened by
widespread deforestation and protected
by international treaties
at nearly four feet in length the birds
were particularly difficult to stuff
into a suitcase but he maneuvered 39 of
them inside by gently curling their
sweeping tails into tight coils
edwin had lost track of how long he'd
been in the vault when he finally
wheeled his suitcase to a stop before a
large cabinet
a small plaque indicated its contents
parody said
37 king birds of paradise swiped in
seconds
24 magnificent rifle birds
12 superb birds of paradise and to show
you what we're talking about here
okay wrapping up the prologue here and
then we'll get into it um
the guard glanced at the cctv feed an
array of shots in the parking lot and
the museum campus
he began his round pacing the hallways
checking the doors scanning for anything
awry edwin had long since lost count of
the number of birds that passed through
his hands he had originally planned to
choose only the best of each species but
in the excitement of the plunder he
grabbed and stuff until his suitcase
could hold no more
the guard stepped outside to begin a
perimeter check glancing up at the
windows and beaming his flashlight on
the section abutting the brick wall of
bank alley
edwin stood before the broken window now
framed with shards of glass so far
everything had gone according to plan
all that remained was to climb back out
of the window without slicing himself
open and melt back into the anonymity of
the street
now
when i first heard about this crime
um
the two big questions that i began with
in my investigation
were these one what what was this
collection
at the british museum the second largest
in the world they have 750 000
bird skins they have miles of birds on
shelves and spirits
hundreds of thousands of eggs what were
they doing there i didn't know anything
about i thought all there was with the
natural history museum was just what you
see displayed in the cases on your
school field trips
um were they as the feather thief
claimed just sitting in some basement
gathering dust or did they have some
other purpose
and the second question is when on earth
possessed
edwin wrist a 20 year old american to
scale the wall that night and to steal
them
to what end
the best way to answer that first
question is to introduce you to this guy
and i gather there are a lot of
ornithologists
uh
tuned in today so they they'll know him
right away but this is alfred russell
wallace
um
best way to to get into this this this
was a
someone who i mean there are there's
shelves sagging with biographies of
wallace so i won't i won't do the whole
run through but but
the the compressed version as he was
inspired by by darwin and the voyage of
the beagle to to
go out in pursuit uh of an answer to the
question that was bedeviling naturalist
at the time what is the origin of
species
and young wallace who was not a highly
educated guy
saved up his money and booked passage to
brazil where he spent four years in
intense privation building a collection
of specimens
birds beetles sketches
you know
fish skeletons uh you know everything he
could uh because the the thinking was
that you go and build this collection up
and bring it back home and spend the
next
you know part of your career
closely evaluating these specimens and
looking for points of divergence and
what inferences you might make
um
and after four years he loads all these
things up on a on a boat and
about a week or so into the voyage back
home he's uh
woken by a shipmate telling him that the
ship is on fire
and he scampers up to the deck and he
can see the smoke curling up through the
planks of the ship and and he knows
everything is is gone he had something
like ten thousand bird skins um
uh like a
it would have been a career establishing
uh
uh collection
um
as as the crew as the crewmen were
jumping onto the life rafts he scampered
down and and grabbed a couple of his
notebooks and a pocket watch and a
sextant and barely escaped but he
returned to london threadbare broke uh
and with really not much to his name but
astonishingly he
he wrote his way into the scientific
establishment and published two books
within the next 18 months a number of
journal articles
and
was sort of invited into a lot of these
royal societies who then backed his next
uh expedition which was
roughly eight years in the malay
archipelago
um now while he was there in the malay
archipelago
he was the first
uh oops where is there we go
uh
western naturalist to lay eyes on
on
this this is the the king bird of
paradise
um
and it was an astonishing thing to him
he um
he described this as
uh having an otherworldly beauty an
intense cinnabar red body a rich orange
head deep metallic green spots above the
eyes
um and he was overcome wallace
wrote that he said i thought of the long
ages of the past during which the
successive generations of this little
creature had run their course year by
year being born and living and dying
amid these dark and gloomy woods with no
intelligent eye to gaze upon their
loveliness to all appearances such a
wanton waste of beauty
but then
wallace recognized that he he understood
what the threat was of what he described
as you know if civilized man were to
ever discover
these birds that he would come charging
in and basically disrupt
the the conditions the world that gave
rise to this beauty and and kill it off
and he wrote that this this
consideration must surely tell us that
all living things were not made for man
um and and one thing to notice this is
an extraordinary i feel embarrassed
describing any birds in front of rick
here but just
pay attention to those tail feathers
because they'll come up in a moment here
but these are these sort of
jade
discs that that um
that in the in the
mating display the king bird of paradise
will kind of wobble these things back
and forth and it's an extraordinary
thing to to witness
um
now i'm not going to get into the whole
uh extraordinary story but of of what
happened with wallace but while he's
there he basically
contracts malaria and in a malarial
fever
uh
pieces together in the theory of
evolution through natural selection
he's impatiently waiting for his fever
to break and he writes
the first paper intended for publication
to to proffer an answer uh to this
question and he puts it in the mail and
sends it to charles darwin uh i'm not
suggesting that darwin stole it but it
did spur darwin into kind of
accelerating his own publication
schedule of the origin of species
um now wallace returned to
to london
with his collection intact
um
and sets out to write uh this incredible
book called the malay archipelago which
you should read if you haven't but i
just want to touch back on his his
premonition of what would happen if
quote unquote civilized man were to
discover these birds
uh and that threat came quicker than he
anticipated in the form of
this um
the
the victorian feather fever uh if if
there is such a thing as a patient zero
we think it's marie antoinette who
who wedged a diamond encrusted egret
feather into her into her hair and set
off this kind of global
uh
arms race
where women were competing to show
status by by wearing
feathers in their hair or entire bird
skins
uh mounted to their hats um
this this set off a a worldwide
destruction uh it seemed that whatever
species was in vogue that month would be
pushed to the brink of extra extirpation
at least
um
by
by one historian's account it's the
single largest direct extermination of
wildlife um
by by humans and it was to feed this
marketplace
uh which was itself inflamed by
you know new
innovations in mass media like rotary
printing presses and magazines that were
pushing these images throughout the
world the the inaugural cover of vogue
for example
has a a woman with feathers in her hat
um
you can see an example here i mean that
it might be hard to see but on the left
that's a photo of an auction lot and i
think there's a thousand hummingbirds
for sale there some of the things that i
um came across while researching this
book were horrifying i mean
coats that were being sold that had
there was one shawl that was made of 7
500 hummingbird skins stitched together
um
uh on the right was a kind of uh i mean
it's from punch magazine which is a kind
of satirical
um
publication but criticizing women's
fashion for for
for
leading to the
uh destruction of bird life but um but
lest it seem that i'm kind of
uh pointing a damning finger at at women
it was
men doing much of the killing and it was
also women that led the the charge to
pull us back from the brink it was women
that revitalized them a moribund audubon
society
it was women that founded the royal
society for the protection of birds
um and
both of these have pledges that you know
their memberships have to their members
have to take an oath not to not to wear
feathers or to to wear bird skins
and
this was a sort of revitalization or
some some people have argued like a
a new birth of the conservation movement
was to pull us back from bird slaughter
the first
the first wildlife refuge set up in the
united states was to cut down on on
snowy egret poachers in the florida
everglades
um at that time in the early 1900s an
egret was egret's plumes were worth
something like four times their weight
in gold
um now
alfred russell wallace was no dummy he
understood that
um with with the industrialized
slaughter of bird life playing out
across the planet he began to implore
the british museum
to
to protect
his specimens and others but to maintain
a collection for future generations
um
he knew he described these birds as the
individual letters that make up the
the words and the sentences and
ultimately the volumes of the earth's
deep history and if we allow them to be
destroyed then we're basically blinding
ourselves to the past
um upon his death in 1913
um
the the british museum
added his collection um
uh his his specimens to their collection
but the threat to them commenced that
immediately in world war one there were
200 000 pounds of
of thermite bombs dropped by german
zeppelins over london in world war ii
there were 28 direct hits on the natural
history museum in london
uh which prompted the curators then to
to marshal a fleet of unmarked trucks to
basically secret these birds out in the
dead of night to a countryside
uh
museum in the town of tring
where they were
where they were
assumed to finally be safe from outside
threat wallace understood that these
specimens likely held answers to
questions that scientists hadn't even
thought of yet and so the stakes here
were huge
um
when no one could have
imagined that after surviving
hitler
uh that the ultimate threat to these
birds would come from a victor from a
from an american fly tire
uh in the 21st century and this leads us
to the second question so what prompted
edwin to climb the wall that night and
to steal these things and the quickest
way to
to show you that is to give and is to do
this is like a
compressed video here but this is
this is what we're talking about this is
a victorian salmon fly
these things can take upwards of eight
eight plus hours to tie
uh and they are
uh tied according to
these 19th century
books that
have kind of are revered as and almost
sort of monastic
uh
religious
uh
levels in terms of like the the
adherence to the particular recipes that
these flies have at the same time that
women were showing off their status by
wearing these birds these exotic birds
and their hats
their aristocratic husbands were
plucking feathers off and and tying them
into these
admittedly beautiful patterns
uh into salmon flies which that which
took on these fancy names like the jock
scott and the green highlander and the
evangeline and exordium
now it's it's work it's
worth mentioning here um
that
what we know of salmon now or is that
they're
just you know essentially colored blind
when they're when they're spawning
they're not there's no you don't have to
be an evolutionary biologist to
piece together that there's no
there's no earthly reason why a salmon
in scotland would ever come across a
bird of paradise feather from from the
highlands of new guinea
but
this was uh an uh essentially an art
form that um
was hugely popular in the 19th century
kind of slipped into a a very
uh
[Music]
near oblivion in the 20th century until
the birth of the internet uh at which
point these books resurfaced and
uh and ebay came and a lot of people
started finding these women's hats and
their in their grandma's attic and and
also these birds that they hadn't seen
before
were available to buy
um
and
and so this then brings us to young
edwin wrist
um
born in in manhattan
raised in hudson valley
uh he was 10 years old when he was
walking through his parents living room
when his dad who was a freelance
journalist
was
writing a piece for popular mechanics on
the physics of of
casting a fly
and he was watching an orvis sort of 101
video
and
edwin walked through the room
when they were demonstrating how to tie
a simple trout fly
and there's a point in the process where
there's there's a technique called paul
marine hackle but where you take a
feather you tie it to the hook and then
when you
you can take an ordinary you know
chicken feather and when you coil it
around the shank of the hook every one
of those little fibers splays out and it
turns something that's very
ordinary looking into something that is
extraordinary looking and for for trout
fishing where you're actually tying
flies that are made to resemble
the insect life
in and around the river
there's a purpose to this the those
feathers could be used these are not
exotic or rare feathers like i said
they're turkey or chicken
but they might
be used to help the fly stay afloat on
the surface of the river or to mimic
you know uh
[Music]
um
the legs of the insect um but edwin was
just ensorcelled by this um and
raised to the basement found some some
fishing hooks ran to his parents bedroom
and pulled some feathers from his mom's
pillow
and started trying to tie his own flies
he was at the time a already a a
virtuoso flautist and so in between
um
you know
studying and
practicing the flute he became an
obsessive trout fly tire
and his parents
uh who were homeschooling him would take
him to these uh
these
tournaments throughout new england uh
i've been to them they're uh
they if they sound a little nerdy they
they are and i say this as someone who's
a
as a someone who is a fly fisherman but
they're picture large ballrooms with uh
tons of booths of celebrity fly tires
who are all hunched over little vices
um tying tying flies and and edwin would
compete where you know they would
tell you you need to tie as many of
these flies as you can within within an
hour
and he started mopping up and winning
first prize first prize and it was at
one of these events
that he first came across
these victorian salmon flies and as soon
as he saw them he
fell in love with them
uh realized that he no longer wanted to
tie these sort of drab ugly looking
trout flies he wanted to tie these
extraordinarily beautiful salmon flies
and he uh
started getting private tutoring from a
master fly tire up in maine
uh but
he immediately was confronted with a
problem this 15 year old did not have
much disposable income
uh
when compared to the other
members of this sort of uh
underground community so a bird would
come up on ebay but he was never able to
to afford it because there were
grown men spending thousands of dollars
on it for their own feather collection
[Music]
so
i mean edwin despite this uh i mean he
was able to use what that community
refers to as subs but substitute
feathers where their dyed
uh you know pheasant or turkey or
chicken feathers died to look like the
exotic uh recipes in these 19th century
books
uh he was he got so good at this that he
was hailed as the future of fly time
uh in fly tire magazine which uh to my
wife's
embarrassment uh
i've been a subscriber too for years now
when i when i first discovered this
story um
but uh but as good as he was his his
mastery of this was always defined by a
kind of longing for what he couldn't
afford
and so at 18 when he was admitted to the
royal academy of music in london he
receives an email right before leaving
from a friend of his and a mentor who
said
hey while you're there
you've got to get into this collection
you've got to see these birds that will
blow your mind do whatever you do
whatever you need to do but get in there
and see the natural history museum's
collection
so
edwin
lies to the british museum
says that he's a
photographer who needs to take photos of
alfred russell wallace's birds of
paradise on behalf of a friend who's
doing a dissertation on them
and the museum
trusting him um
which you know to be fair it's not
i don't condemn them for that these as
rick can attest this is
these are
the curators are stewards of these
collections and they're there to advance
human human knowledge they can't exist
in a bunker where nobody can see them
but that calibration has has be deviled
museums all over the world of who gets
in and who doesn't and how do you assess
risk
and it's certainly been complicated by
by the story you're about to hear
but he goes to tring
signs his name into the log book and and
they
he's deposited in front of uh
i think the red rough fruit crow was
maybe the first uh
species that he was allowed to
photograph and he starts snapping
pictures but while he's there he also
starts taking pictures of
of the location of the cabinets and the
windows and the entry and exit points
and he's building a kind of visual map
of the museum
now
it took me
uh nearly four years to get him to agree
to an interview but i in that interview
i asked him to describe
how it felt uh when he was
inside the sort of
private uh or non-public part of the
british museum and this is how he
described it
so
you can tell us as soon as he's there
you know encountering these i mean for
example the
the natural history museum in trang had
um
48 red rough fruit crows which were
selling for something
at the time they were selling for
something like six thousand dollars per
skin
he would pull open tray after tray of
birds and see
massive extraordinary
financial value
but he also as a
fly tire saw the creative potential that
he
if he had these things he would be able
to tie whatever he wanted without
having the pressure of scarcity
so as i as you heard in the
in the prologue but he
uh
he ends up taking these things after
eight months of plotting this heist um
and he
during those eight months leading up to
the heist he registered edwinrisk.com
which he set up as a sort of online
marketplace um
he
ordered these you know the diamond blade
glass cutter and other things on ebay he
this part just seemed impossible to be
true but he created a
uh a word document with uh which was
entitled plan for museum invasion dot
dot
uh where he sort of uh
built his strategy
and then after performing
um
in london boarded the train
stole 299 specimens
from the museum of those 48 redraft
fruit crows he stole 47 of them he just
the guards think that or the curators
think that he just didn't see one that
was kind of wedged in the back of the
drawer
um crucially the
i mean some of these species that the
numbers are smaller but i think he took
i have to check but i think he took
something like 17 flame bauer birds
um which may not seem like a significant
number but there were some at the time
there was something like 30 flame bower
birds in all of the research
institutions in the world
um and in case it
should be obvious but what you know
some of these birds have been there and
preserved by this chain of curators
since before the word scientist was even
coined
so once you steal a
a bird
gathered from
from this forest or this island in 1850
that bird might still be there now but
you can't go and get to get another one
from that
from 1850 i mean this seems blindingly
obvious but um but the the whole point
of these collections is to have these
sort of almost like uh genetic snapshots
of of
you know what
what the species was like back then and
and uh so that we can understand how
things are changing
so
um
the the guard did not whether he was
watching a soccer match uh or not he did
not catch edwin that night he climbed
back out
uh he missed the train back to london
and spent a very kind of
an angst-ridden
three or four hours
at this tiny
train stop with a million dollars worth
of dead birds in a suitcase uh you know
terrified the cops were coming for him
got back to his dorm room spread the
birds out on the bed
told uh one family member that he he
felt like the richest uh
man in the world um
having these collections and then
proceeded to start
uh
chopping them up
and hacking the
you know the breastplates which are the
only thing that fly
tires care about of the redro frucrow
he would hack those out and he he took a
series of approaches sometimes he would
sell
um
uh here's his website and i i have
it's especially
uh
great to be able to do this
uh with with yelling with rick today
because
when rick first heard about this um
he had the foresight to take these
screenshots the only ones that exist of
edwin's
website which were subsequently
you know obliterated from the web
but these are to anyone watching this
who
was a curator works with these
collections these are obviously study
specimens these are museum specimens
that he's posting
on a public site he's using their latin
binomials he's not he's not even using
the slang for these things
um
but he would he would sell full birds
one american uh dentist there's a lot of
dentists in this story i think it's
because
dentists are good with
working with little tools and tight
spaces and so i kept never that's my
best theory but one american dentist
boarded a plane for london and and
bought something like ten thousand
dollars worth of birds
all of these guys that bought from edwin
and we're talking about a total of like
some several hundred thousand dollars
worth of stuff that the british
authorities
allege that he sold
none of them
seemed to wonder or maybe did not want
to to ask how a college student was
suddenly sitting upon the most valuable
private collection of priceless
exotic specimens in the world but but
they were quite happy to just do the
transactions
now
here you'll see some of my obsessive
screen shotting over the years but
here's a these are private facebook
group exchanges where they're
they're stressing to each other that you
never talk about the price you only do
this over over private message
these are birds where you can see the
tags um
which bear all the bio data on the tied
onto their tie to their feet
um
he would also um
my screen just froze here here we go you
would also post photos like this to
these forums
um
where
you have to understand some of these
you know that bottom row of feathers but
you know six of them
are are a hundred dollars
and
i remember asking rick this but i think
the breastplate would have has something
like maybe 800 feathers on it every
single bird and he stole 48 of them or
47 of them so you can do the math of how
quickly this becomes lucrative
here this is
july 27 2010
this is before
before
the arrest uh before he was eventually
caught the the flight time forums that
he would sell these on are joking about
uh the price that edwin is charging and
and the the three thousand percent
markup that he's that he's making on
birds stolen from a natural history
museum
now the
it took the british museum 35 days to
realize that they were actually missing
specimens they the the morning after the
heist
they raced over to to the cabinets
collect
housing darwin's birds
uh and it's kind of a final blow to
wallace but had they had they cared
about wallace as much as darwin they
probably would have
uh checked wallace's specimens as well
and realized that they had been burgled
but they
they concluded within a day or so that
it was a sort of failed
break and enter and and basically
breathe the sigh of relief and it wasn't
until a month or so later that
a visiting researcher came and opened up
the trays the trays that were
[Music]
supposed to be holding the red rough
fruit crows and found them empty and so
the museum then did an inventory they
made the tally they announced
the heist um
the detective assigned to the case did a
number of interviews of the staff to to
rule out an inside job
but
i mean the british museum
doesn't like this characterization i can
understand why but i i think they
quickly just came to
uh
an assumption that
the birds had probably all been chopped
up um
i for the life of me i don't uh i don't
understand
i've been through this many times now
but uh
you know edwin wrist was emailing them
about the very birds that were
subsequently stolen
they were
he signed his real name into their
logbook
um
but for whatever reason it it took 15
months for law enforcement to finally
turn their eyes
on edwin and that was not because of
with all respect to
the
the wonderful british detective who was
running point on this case
uh it wasn't because of gumshoe work it
was because another
um
officer
um
who was not assigned to the case um but
who was an avid fly tire went to a
festival in holland where he saw
um
someone showing off a priceless specimen
uh and he started
you know he he knew about the train
heist and he started asking questions
and so that
that law enforcement officer who i'm
obligated to
uh protect his anonymity but he's the
one that tipped off the authorities and
that led to edwin's arrest
um now
uh
i want to i want to get us to q a but um
i don't want to go through every twist
and turn of of my subsequent
investigation but
um
but
a couple photos here of the crime scene
evidence so of the 299 birds stolen
the police recovered 102 of them that
were intact with their labels attached
which is a crucial detail the labels are
cut off they're essentially
meaningless for research or greatly
diminished for research
72 were intact but were missing their
labels
and beyond that they found a mountain of
ziploc bags filled with severed parts of
birds
after the news of the arrest and other
19 skins all of them missing their their
labels were returned by mail anonymously
and as far as the skins still at large
about a third of them
were still missing
and so even though and here you'll see
the resplendent quetzals where the tales
have been hacked off and and sold off to
the community
um
but even though the
the british museum described this as a
catastrophic theft from humanity
and even though they still hadn't
recovered a huge number of skins they
announced
after the arrest that we're quote where
please the matter is resolved
um
when i first heard about this and then
realized that
not only had this really happened
because it just seemed so impossibly
strange but that there was still
you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars worth of these skins and
feathers floating around
this sort of
black market um and that
uh that the feather thief had basically
had never spent a night behind bars and
we can get into that in q a but he he
was basically given a slap on the wrist
he was allowed to graduate from the
royal academy of music and go on his way
that the that the british authorities
were no longer looking for the specimens
uh and that i was seen as i was getting
deeper into the what i kind of jokingly
call the feather underground that they
were basically just cracking jokes about
it all
um that it struck me as
wrong on a very
basic level
uh and so
this was a
a five plus year investigation where i
went all over the world infiltrating
this community turning people into
sources
um
and i'm happy to discuss that
investigation but uh but
among the most shocking revelations of
it
uh i'm now at five separate museum
heights that have been carried out by
fly tires in the last 20 years
um edwin's
was the worst that we know of but it's
by no mean a nice by no means an
isolated occurrence
even when i launched this book the first
event launching this book was at the los
angeles natural history museum
and shortly before the event the the
head of their bird collection took me
over and showed me a cabinet and showed
me the crowbar marks where somebody had
pried open a case and stolen
the same species of birds
that were
targeted in the train heist
there's a
an american fly tire who was posing he
had a
he won a pest control uh
uh contract with a couple museums in in
europe and he would go in at night and
spray for
for insects and then he would take
priceless birds into his coveralls and
and slip out um he was never caught
um
so um
you know i just i just wanted to say
that this is a uh this is a story that
i initially thought was just kind of a
quirky
you know why on earth would people
steal
steel birds but it very quickly became
something much more profound about our
relationship to the to a changing
planet and vanishing
wildlife and also
the kind of blinders that that of
obsession can give to people
just to end it on a lighter note um
towards the end of what was an
eight-hour interview with the feather
thief
i was trying to lighten the mood and i i
said
hey you know like when you when you go
on a date with somebody do you do you
feel like the need to say just so you
know like
i'm a feather thief but i'm you know
whatever and i saw his
his
brow furrow when i used the word thief
and i said well is that a problem like
you do not like that word and this is
how he answered
i hope hopefully you could hear that i
don't know if the audio was good enough
but um
you know i'm not a psychiatrist or
psychologist but i think the the term
for that is compartmentalization
uh so all right so i'm gonna stop my
my screen share here uh and and i i
would love to uh dive into questions if
you have any uh but again i'm really
grateful to
to rick and to the to the frankies and
yale for for making this happen and i i
hope that sets the table enough here for
us to
to have a chat
great thank thanks so much kirk and uh
and uh
and um i'll just say that uh since uh
nobody has to get in a car and drive
home uh you know we're here we're gonna
uh let the questions uh go with uh for a
while um thanks kirk you know uh it's
always striking to be reminded of this
and obviously you documented how the
worldwide impact on scientific capacity
to study
these uh this is this biodiversity
uh i'm really struck by
that uh that description uh of or or uh
edwin's description of himself as
somebody who really understands the
feathers
you know for him somebody really
understands the feathers is what what
they materially do
as you wrap them around a hook uh not
the role of feathers in the biology of
the bird
exactly
and and and you probably
i imagine you probably were pulling your
hair out if
when you got to this point in the book
but i mean he he was pushing a
a mountain of just junk science uh in
the interview where he said you know
essentially
uh after a hundred years you can't you
can't really pull any dna from them
anymore and and uh you know all the the
real value is really just in the you
know height and weight and that's kind
of it so um
there were a lot of points where
i had your kind of your
as you described it many graduate
seminar in my head during the interview
where i wanted to
to say are you nuts but i just i just
i wanted to just let him
he sort of hang himself with these
comments that makes sense yeah well we
have lots of great questions i just
remind people uh if you have questions
put them in the q a we're monitoring it
um
uh first from from kd is wrist still
tying flies
oh that's a great question one that i
don't think i can i can't answer
definitively but um
because as you might imagine he
he and i are not really close at this
point
um uh but he he claims that he's not uh
and i have not seen
any
hosts of his uh in these
communities where you would see them so
uh if if he is he's doing it privately
and from judith a question whatever
became of edwin's brother was he
implicating the crimes uh uh and theft
or later sales
uh his brother is
last i checked
principal or first chair uh clarinetist
at the met
uh so he's this is a remarkably talented
family uh he was not implicated in this
um
uh
and as as best as i know uh
was not involved yeah
yeah so um this uh we have a whole
series of questions just aghast uh amy
why wasn't he jailed and convicted
stanley isn't receiving stolen goods a
crime couldn't some of the fly making
community be identified and prosecuted
um i know myself but before we met i was
calling fish and wildlife service
talking about my experiences of seeing
specimens that were being sold at uh at
shows and um
why is there more of a crackdown
well the
to answer that um
and i've you know i've spent quite a bit
of time talking to fish and wildlife
folks as well
um
the truth is uh that they are motivated
by
rhinoceros and elephant and sexier busts
than
fly tires with packs of of
illicit feathers now i
i was
at some point in this investigation i
was basically just cold calling and cold
emailing people
within the agency saying why aren't you
guys
paying attention to this because i was i
was on ebay
constantly i i was pulling so many
records of
sales of cities protected species on
ebay that i had to hire an assistant to
basically build this excel sheet
and i shared that with fish and wildlife
uh and it was only then that they
i can say all this now it'll i'll
explain in a second but they
they finally called me and said that
they were opening an investigation into
this that it was going to be a like an
active case with with an agent or two
assigned to it and would i sign on as a
confidential informant i can say that
because i'm the least
like
if there were crackdowns like who do you
think the guy was that tipped off the
feds like it's pretty obvious that it
was me
um but the timing of it is crucial
because that phone call happened in
december of 2016.
[Music]
uh which was the penultimate month of
the obama administration and so then
when trump came in the
the kind of
fledgling
case just sort of was closed after that
so
um they don't it's not a priority of
theirs um
and the question of how edwin got away
with it um
you know
it's a it's a big part of the book but
uh but essentially he
his lawyers got him in front of borat's
cousin
simon baron cohen who is sasha baron
cohen's cousin
who is
one of the
sort of
leading experts on asperger's
and over the course of like a one hour
or so assessment of edwin he concluded
that edwin had asperger's and therefore
didn't really realize what he was doing
now i mean
i've had a lot of people write to me
that uh you know
you know
asperger's doesn't even exist as a
stand-alone diagnosis anymore but that
people are on the spectrum often have a
heightened awareness of right and wrong
that that just because you're you're on
the spectrum doesn't mean that you don't
recognize that
plotting a museum heist for a year and
stealing things that aren't yours is a
wrong thing it's a kind of an offensive
thing but but the brits um
they were able to basically cite a
series of of precedents in british case
law where people
with an assessment of asperger's were
then not ever sent uh to prison and
obviously americans we
we want to throw everyone in prison so
i'm not advocating that but um but he he
truly was not
uh punished he had a a
confiscation order for something like
10 or 15 000 and then and then he was
sent on his way so um there really was
no meaningful punishment here
yeah
uh one uh user asks uh how much pushback
have you gotten from the fly tying
community uh
since uh the publication
well it's interesting because um
one thing i neglected to mention is that
the
overwhelming majority of
the men who tie salmon flies and i say
men because
i spent years researching this and i did
not find a single woman who was tiny i
got excited because at one point i saw
a woman posting flies on facebook but it
was just her husband using her account
but overwhelmingly the men that tied the
victorian salmon flies
do not fish at all they don't know how
to fish they don't own the gear this is
just an art form for them and i mean
quite honestly you'd have to be a
lunatic to cat to throw up to cast a two
thousand uh two thousand dollars worth
of feathers into a river when you can
catch salmon with dog fur tied to a hook
i mean i had some one angler write to me
uh with a photo of of a
a great salmon that he caught with a he
had run out of
flies and he tied a candy bar wrapper to
his hook and caught one salmon aren't
easy to catch but they're not
they're not drawn to these particular
feathers obviously so
um
the there's a dike there's a very
pronounced dichotomy the ones who don't
know how to fish and who tie these
salmon flies they hate me they hate the
book
the fly the fly fisherman the guide that
first tipped me off to this story 10
years ago in new mexico
has twice had to go to local law
enforcement for
specific death threats that he's
received from this community for the sin
of of telling me about this story in the
first place
um
but the other the rest of the community
which are actual anglers and people who
uh
who know how to fish and who are using
trout flies and who have a kind of maybe
a more realistic awareness and
appreciation of nature and of
conservation
um they all love the book uh and
celebrate but my biggest antagonist with
this book have been classic sam and fly
tires and the british museum which is
one of the only museums on earth that
won't
that just won't carry the book you can't
find it in their gift shop so
uh so yeah it's a strange i mean i think
the british museum never
they they weren't able to step
past their embarrassment to recognize
that this entire book was a love letter
to them and to their mission and to
their institution
and that i spent all of this time going
around the world trying to track down
these skins so that they could be
returned to that museum
for the proper use of these specimens um
but but i think they were
you know more concerned with what they
call reputational damage so yeah um we
have a question from raquel uh the
disrespectful attitude of the fly tying
community aside is there an argument to
be made that fly tires also have valid
appreciation of these specimens
for the purpose of art and beauty if not
for scientific knowledge what if the
museum were to sell some of their extras
once the scientific data had been
collected
i think you should answer that one
well you know i uh
yes well you know the interesting thing
is that they're uh we never reach an end
result of when uh
we've collected all the data because in
fact obviously dna wasn't described
until uh you know uh
nearly a hundred years after uh uh
you know uh uh
wallace wrote his paper or collected
many of these specimens
and now and in fact we can still and we
do get better and better at acquiring
lots of useful dna uh specimens up from
the thing so so that that notion is is
wrong and the other the other part about
it is um
that uh we are incredibly highly
regulated to make collections uh
uh today uh requires lots and lots of
permits which have to go through lots
and lots of uh ongoing uh regulation and
uh um so uh the the
the uh
those permits would not be given for the
purposes of making art and indeed you
know one of the interesting things about
this is its roots in
uh
victorian mercantile you know
colonialism right though all those
feathers all those uh girls who were
inventing these flies
back in the victorian era were buying
these because they were available from
all of the colonies that uh that had
been gathered right so it's really a
return to that kind of concept of the
world that that that allows this art
form to exist and
some forms ought to go extinct you know
and i think you know just looking at one
of the comments but like the the
you know initially
when i knew nothing about any of this
stuff um i thought well isn't there
something to it i remember talking to
you about this rick like but that they
here are guys who really
love and appreciate these birds and but
there was a it quickly
their appreciation for them
is
in a kind of
i've used the word deliberately but it's
in a cult-like
appreciation where they
there is a um
there are certain series of flies that
are supposed to only be tied with a
particular type of feather and when you
see when you go deep into all of this
these guys talk about the kind of
exquisite quality of how this feather
can be married to another feather and
the way that the the rakes bends
differently than a chicken feather would
and and all this and so but it's not
there's zero science to any of it
and so that's where like you know i felt
like anyone
myself included like at some point you
have to
you have to pick a side here like is
this just an aesthetic pursuit and and
beauty for beauty's sake
or
or are do these things should they be
used for the the advancement of human
knowledge and i i very
clearly ended up in in the latter camp
uh but yeah
there are so many uh uh great questions
here we won't get to all of them but i
just want to highlight we have uh uh
guy kerwin uh
author of mannequins and continues of
the world a monograph of the family
right do you think that risk
does not consider himself a thief
because he wasn't incarcerated
um
i don't know how to answer that to be
honest i i think um
i think he still
believes that these specimens have no
uh
rightful place in museums
and that the the that the it's the
curators and in fact you know the the
south african that i
uh opened this talk with
admitted to me in an on the record
interview that he still has many of
these birds
that he bought from edwin but he refuses
to send them back to the british museum
uh because he doesn't care but also
because he believes that these curators
are doing the devil's work and that
they're pushing evolution and all this
sort of satanic stuff in his mind and
also he knows that um
that
this is not going to rise to the level
of like an interpol international
operation to go and reclaim these things
especially if the british museum is not
clamoring for it
um and so
you know i think if you
if you discount the value of the thing
that you stole then i think it makes it
easier to
discount the
the
your own culpability in it and so that's
my best guess at why he could say like
he's not a thief
yeah yeah well last question i've lost
uh
in defeat but uh um do you uh worry that
this uh may
uh actually encourage future uh
future thefts
yeah i mean it it certainly crossed my
mind but um i will say that one of the
consequences of this book has been uh
and i i see that there's a lot of
curators on the thread here but um
this does seem to have led to something
of a
of
a wake up
in the curator community where
you know i
went to the smithsonian and they now
have locks on the on the specimens that
are referenced in in um in the feather
thief i gave a talk in denver and some
deep pocketed donor at the denver museum
went up to the curators at the end of my
talk and and wrote a check or committed
a huge amount of money to them to
upgrade their security for the
collection
um i have been
which was not a
desire of mine to be totally honest but
a sort of unofficial security consultant
to this community where i get emails
regularly
from museums around the world
who are forwarding
requests uh for access to their
collections from people who they suspect
might be salmon fly tires
and on more than one occasion i've had
to
write to these institutions to say like
no you absolutely should not let this
person person in knowing what i know
about them
uh i you know
i don't think my wife isn't particularly
thrilled that you know that career shift
of me becoming a museum security
consultant but even you know even
occidental out here i live in los
angeles and
um occidental has the more lab of
zoology and
um
i'm i'm close friends with with the head
of that lab john mccormick who i mean he
just sent me
proudly
uh like a screenshot of all of their new
surveillance and security measures and
things like that so um so
i i think there are probably new people
that have entered this community of fly
time but it's also
i think become a lot harder to steal
these things
yeah yeah yeah
well i'm sorry that we won't have time
to get into all the rest of the
questions uh
but at this point i want to thank you
the audience uh for your tennis and
thanks kirk uh
and
best uh wishes uh best good luck with
the launch of the new book
um and i look forward to to that read as
well as this and i know we'd have a
great uh uproarious applause if we're
all together but you certainly have mine
uh thank you very much kirk
thank you thank you all for having me
thank you rick and thank you everyone
for attending thank you kirk and thanks
once again tai and guy for
helping uh make this such a success
bye everyone and see you next week